Okay. So today I want to start the show by
talking about the strategy of the 2020 democratic
primaries.
So I'm not gonna Focus so much on political
issues today as far as what positions do I
agree with and don't I agree with, if you've
been watching this show, if you've been listening
to the podcast or the radio show for awhile,
you know that my politics for example, or
to the left of Joe Biden's, so I would like
a more progressive nominee. I liked Bernie
Sanders. I Like Elizabeth Warren, uh, from
the sort of more well known candidates. Uh,
I like some of Andrew Yang's ideas, although
I have questions about the way he would implement
some of them. But the point is, Joe Biden
is a Hillary Clinton centrist. And while I
think Joe Biden's a great debater, as I've
said before, that doesn't mean that I actually
want Joe Biden to be president of the United
States, given other options. Joe's politics
are to my right. But I've made it really clear
that if Biden's the nominee, I'm not going
to vote for him in the primary, but if he
wins the primary Biden's the nominee, I'm
sure as hell voting for Joe Biden over Donald
Trump.
But that's the sort of political stuff. I
don't want to talk so much about the politics,
but what instead is the strategy of running
another sentence, a centrist Democrat against
Donald Trump after what happened in 2016 with
Hillary Clinton. One of the biggest red flags
for me when it comes to strategy from Joe
Biden came on day one of Joe Biden's campaign
where he didn't really do an announcement
where he presents his ideas, his platform.
He didn't even tout to many of his credentials,
which are actually numerous, uh, although
they still don't make them anything other
than a centrist Biden focused on Charlottesville
and Trump. So we'll see whether this changes
as Joe Biden keeps campaigning. But his opening
statement, his announcement video was a let's
defeat Trump's speech, which to me is already
the wrong strategy and is having a, a a is
triggering in my mind, memories of some elements
of 2016 focusing on let's defeat Trump is
like running a campaign on we will indict
Trump or we will impeach Trump. Leave that
up to the current elected officials in the
House and Senate.
Let them figure out our impeachment proceedings.
The right thing is impeachment debate the
right thing, 25th amendment, whatever, right?
If you think Trump should be impeached, say
it as some candidates have said, but the campaign
can't just be about, uh, Trump is bad Charlottesville
and I'm going to be better. So problem one
for Biden in strategy is that so far it's
been hugely about the platform is get rid
of Donald Trump. And I'm, the person says
Joe Biden to get rid of Donald Trump. And
he may be, but this is not the right way to
go about it. So that's problem number one.
Problem number two with Biden's campaign is
that Biden is playing around the edges and
not with the plot or to use like a literature
analogy, Biden's running a campaign, but he's
touting only the prologue and the acknowledgements
page at the end of the book rather than the
actual substance.
Right. And what I mean by that is this recent
example Biden talked about finding a middle
ground on climate change. That's a pro status
quo establishment framing, finding a middle
ground on climate change, climate change is
a crisis. We need systemic change to deal
with that issue. Uh, our Wa modally has a
really good article about this in the Guardian.
Biden is not someone who has said, because
I don't think he believes that we need significant
systemic change in America to solve the major
issues of our time. Those being campaign finance,
how politics is finance climate change, the
massive inequality that has created all sorts
of overclass and underclass structures in
America, including on, on healthcare, including
uneducation, including on just basic, you
know, affording cost of living. Sanders and
Warren are not just offering progressive policies
at the micro level, which I like, but the
macro that they are presenting, Bernie may
be slightly more than than Elizabeth Warren
admittedly, is that we need systemic change.
We need systemic change when it comes to the
primary power relationships that exist in
the United States. Biden proposes some policies,
but it's all about let's get back to center,
left Democratic Establishment Rule status
quo, where we sort of deal with a few symptoms
around the edges. A, we get rid of a president
that won't take white nationalism seriously
in this type of thing. Uh, and these things
are important, but they're not the plot, right?
Yes. Trump has allowed extremism to fester.
It would be great to get rid of Trump and
put in place anyone who would immediately
change tone on that issue. But that's not
a platform and it's certainly not particularly
progressive. So what we need to do is prevent
Biden from being Hilary 2020 whether he wins
or loses the primary. Okay. If you don't like
Biden's politics, do what I'm going to do,
which is you vote in the primary for somebody
else who's more progressive.
If a more progressive candidate doesn't win
and a centrist candidate wins, whether it's
Biden or somebody else, I still think that
they can beat Trump. They just need to play
their cards right. They need to play their
cards right in the key states that Hillary
narrow, narrowly lost Pennsylvania, Wisconsin,
Michigan, there are others. Um, Trump isn't
that popular? Whoa. Punched my mic because
I'm getting so wound up here. Trump isn't
that popular in those states. He can be beaten,
but if it's going to be a centrist Democrat,
they actually need to run their campaign correctly.
And it's not clear at all that Joe Biden is
doing that at this point in time, even though
he is polling very, very well. If Biden wins
the primary and he's polling well, then what
we need to do on the progressive left is make
sure that Biden runs the correct centrist
Democrat campaign so that if it's Biden, he
might actually defeat Donald Trump, not losing
to Trump like Hillary did in 2016 interference
and DNC meddling aside every day, I am seeing
more and more signs that Biden is running
a Hilary 2020 campaign effectively.
And this is a real problem. Uh, and we're
going to have to continue thinking about what
the strategy is going to be during the primary
and what's the strategy of Joe Biden is ultimately
the nominee. I will vote for him over Trump.
There's no question about that. Not even for
a second. I am not going to be part of the
problem a of those who ultimately may help
to, um, uh, put Donald Trump in the White
House for a second term. But we've
got to
keep talking about this for sure.